i love that you brought that class
one more time
matthew matthew we love you brother
i mean talk to us charlie about matthew
man talk to us
matthew
ten days ago
and
immediately i was like i gotta meet you
like he was so inspiring you know
forgive my ignorance i'm
i'm a square what is dmt so i know
he messaged me all right and three hours
later i pulled up at his house and i
just wanted to ask him one question
i was like matthew what's your dream
like you're so inspiring but like what's
your dream because matthew has cerebral
palsy
but the doctors told him he wouldn't he
would be a vegetable
and i'm like no
like yeah he proved them all wrong and
his mindset is proof like you can
overcome but it's he has two dreams his
dream is to be able to walk for the
first time on his own
and the second dream because he's really
inspired by nipsey hustle
i was like okay if you can make a lot of
money to be able to afford the
treatments and the physical therapy and
the equipment to be able to walk how
would you make your money he said i want
to have a clothing line like nipsy
hustle
well
last night his clothing line came out
and he sold
three hundred thousand dollars in the
first 12 hours damn come on come on
matthew
yeah but um what gave you that thought
that's them what gave you that thought
the clothing line thought yeah what gave
you that thought when what was it about
nick rehustle
that gave you that inspiration uh how he
helped
his community
like um uh how we helped
like the people
um strive for success
and um
yeah that
that's what i love about him
i think that's cool you kind of brought
that up pretty profound mike because you
did you because you are right money is
money but the thought that you have in
your mind that you want to manifest is
is priceless right mike incredible
matthew believe it or not even though
like he has a hard time walking and
talking like in school a b student he
went home coming queen he went to
college like he went to elac like very
smart like smarter than
i told i told him you're probably
smarter than all of us in this room
and that's why like when he went to
design his first designs he pulled out a
piece of paper and the things he started
designing were genius i'm like because i
i've done clothing my whole life like
merch and i was like this is some of the
best stuff i've seen
and this is within a few days of meeting
them and i'm like okay
i think he was meant for this so what do
you tell him about this
talent that he possessed you know you
seem to be his mentor what do you tell
him about this talent that he possessed
like
when i saw what he was capable of
i was like okay like he's fully capable
of running a business no doubt
and what he's going to be able to do
with it
because now like like he the the problem
is like with cerebral palsy he needs to
get his muscles strong but
he lives in a vertical apartment and
there's nowhere to walk in the apartment
in the neighborhood he lives in he can't
practice walking outside it's very
dangerous like somebody
you know got killed you know a few doors
down
and
i talked to his mom and she was like it
would just be so nice to be able to live
in a flat home
with in a neighborhood with sidewalks
and so he had that motivation
and like i think there was something
really divine about it like whatever he
channeled and manifested
he manifested
us into his life
and now
they're going to be able to move into
that home he's going to be able to have
the equipment he's going to be able to
overcome and be able to take those first
steps
you know
in all due respect you know no really
what does he know about god oh man
i'll let him speak on that but from what
i've seen
this man's got a direct line
[Music]